[Music]
welcome back to the spectators energy
summits kindly sponsored by
national grid now in our next session
we're going to be asking
what extent the uk's target of achieving
net zero by 2050
complements or conflicts with the
manifesto pledge of
leveling up the government's signature
agenda
the dilemma was put quite well earlier
on by
bin nephilimi when he pointed out that
many of the red wall seats the tories
have just won the two
seats which gave the tories their 80
seat majority
are um rich in industries which are
quite
energy intensive in their economic
profile
so the track the trick is how you manage
to pursue 2015 in a way which doesn't
punish those who've turned tori for the
first time indeed doesn't punish anybody
in any seat will it be inevitably a
trade-off
is it simply the case that's a hit 2050
they're going to be winners and losers
and the losers are going to be in places
like the steel works
a talbot and there isn't many ways of
making it that much
better for them or do new technologies
allow pears to move forward in a way
that doesn't
put energy-intensive jobs out of
work so we're going to be joined now by
lord kurzlich chair of the uk 2070
commission
by andrew carter who's the chief
executive of center for
cities by bennuchen the mayor forties
valley
and by duncan bart who's the cop 26
director
of national grid i'd like to start by
um asking lord kurzlik to give us some
opening remarks
and i'll come i'll do some discussion
afterwards and then we'll be taking
questions from you our audience so
please do send them in either on the
zoom link
or by emailing events at spectator dot
co dot uk lord curse lake over to you
well thank you very much uh fraser i'm
really pleased to be
speaking about two of the long-term
challenges that this country faces
they'll be there
uh after covert and they were there
before covered and they are
in my view fundamental to the future
success of the country
just let me start first with leveling up
or rebalancing i've been chairing a
commission for over two years now on
regional inequalities
and we've produced a number of reports
we particularly want to look
back 50 years and forward 50 years
because we think
it's taken us a while to get to where we
are now and it'll take us a while to get
out of it
hence the name 2017. in our first report
uh we found that the uk was the
almost the most spatially unequal
country uh
in the developed world out of a total of
30 countries measured against 28
indicators
we came 28 eurovision song contest
levels of performance you might describe
it as
and our view was uh that something
needed to change in our second report
we said that uh we were unlikely to
shift on this without a comprehensive
long-term
uh large-scale plan it needed that
level of uh investment of effort both
locally
and nationally to shift the data on uh
regional inequalities and we set out a
10
point action plan number one of those
uh 10 points was embedding
spatial equality into the plan to get to
zero carbon
because our view is that we face a
double-headed crisis here
both uh climate change and the impact of
it being often
most acutely foul in places of low
income and
uh poverty so you need to consciously do
things
in order to get these agendas to align
and that's what we argue very much in
our report we did a third report
in september and in that report we said
that covid had both created challenges
for the leveling up agenda
and made it even more important in fact
we won't
i think respond to covrid without a
major programme of levelling up
we can deliver a sustainable growth now
on the
face of it as you alluded to raise it
these two agendas don't sit well
together
the high carbon uh intense
parts of the industry in this country
have historically
been in the north we've got four million
jobs uh predominantly uh
in the midlands and the north west and
northeast
uh and therefore i think everyone can
see the potential risks that might come
if we don't actively put the two things
together it seems to me
um and if we think of net zero carbon
which is a very
in my view kind of loose phrase
essentially abolishing
the use of fossil fuels you get a better
sense of the challenge here i
i mean sheffield for this event
uh one art welder in sheffield uses the
energy equivalent of the whole of
doncaster
basically just to give you a sense of
the scale
but actually i'm an optimist on this
agenda because there's some fantastic
work going on
at a local level that i think leads the
way
forward on this agenda in our reports we
set out quite a few we're going to hear
from ben hodgson on
the team's value zero carbon issue which
i think is really really powerful
uh and we are in fact uh putting our
money where our mouth is as a commission
and doing
an inquiry with the local council to see
how they can move further
uh forward on their agenda of economic
renewal
but i do think we have to replace the
traditional industries
with new models and in sheffield for
example
we have the advanced manufacturing
research center the advanced well-being
research center that i think paved the
way
to new economic models that can
turn that double-headed crisis that's
been talked about into a double-headed
opportunity but it won't happen without
a combination of a
national plan and
working collaboratively with the private
sector
uh uh and finally local leadership these
these things are crucial to success on
this agenda
lord kurzlik thanks very much indeed i'd
now like to pass
over to andrew carter who's chief
executive of the center for cities
thank you uh frasier so let me um give a
sort of cities and large towns
perspective on the
on these questions or issues so cities
and large towns obviously are
big uh emitters of um of carbon
uh and emissions more generally 50
of all the countries emissions comes
from the 63 biggest
places in britain london alone accounts
for about 10
of that so they're big big emitters
because
there is lots of stuff in them but when
you look at emissions per capita
actually most of our urban areas are
pretty efficient
they're actually below the national
average on a per capita basis
about the emissions and actually the
emissions are reducing more rapidly
uh in our cities and large towns than
they are in other parts of the country
so there's a kind of thought around
in the importance of uh the urban when
we think about how we
uh how we deal with some of these sort
of questions so three ways i think
the cities can contribute to reducing
emissions
helping to tackle unemployment that was
there before the pandemic has been made
worse um through the pandemic and indeed
tackle the questions and issues that bob
was talking about which is
poor long-run productivity and thus
leveling up
part of the agenda so the first thing i
think is one of the ways we can
reduce emissions is actually to increase
density
and activity in our urban areas and
that's about actually building more
homes
enabling more jobs in and around our
urban areas
uh already that requires a plan in
system reform government is thinking
about this
to make it easier for firms and for
councils
to prioritize and develop areas that are
already within their urban footprint
i think that's really important
particularly as it relates
to transport so that's my first thing i
think we can think more about
land use planning and its role in how
the urban footprint expands and
densifies in our urban air second
uh way that cities can help is actually
to support a general move
in different places in different ways
but a general move away from the car
and towards public transport in a sense
we know that
outside of london and probably one or
two of the other big cities
our public transport systems are pretty
poor because of a lack of investment
uh over over a number of decades but we
also know that public transport is much
more efficient
in moving people around and indeed has
lower uh emissions per
uh per passenger so thinking about how
we can encourage
uh move away from the car uh and into
public transport i think is important
that will mean things like
investing in buses you know uh ben is
thinking about what that means uh in a
tease valley context so it's great in
manchester etc so
focus on buses it also probably means
thinking about
introducing low emission zones we have
one uh
in london we have some others that in uh
germination in other places but thinking
about how we can encourage
better public transport and less car
usage where appropriate
i think is my second reason and my third
option or third
way that cities can help is actually to
tackle the domestic energy use
and particularly kind of housing
retrofit we've heard a lot about this
uh since um in the green recovery one in
five
uk homes have particularly poor energy
performance
but when you go to places like burnley
bradford and blackpool
it's one in three of the homes in those
places have particularly poor
uh energy performance whereas if you go
to some of our new towns crawley and
milton keynes
it's only one in ten so a big focus
a very particular and practical focus on
energy
performance in our housing uh sector i
think would pay dividends not only
um from an energy reduction but it's
very labor-intensive so there's a kind
of
employment effect that we would see in
places like burnley and bradford
and blackpool and others so those are my
kind of three ways i think that i think
cities can help
i think thinking about it from a
place-based perspective gives us a way
to bring these different
agendas together and my final point you
know is we need to further empower
leaders like ben and indeed leaders
across
our cities and towns in order for them
to take advantage of and drive
this agenda and to bend investment into
areas that they feel
are appropriate and i'll hand back to
you thank you andrew
and now i'd like to pass over to ben
hutching the mayor for
teas valley who have been in a way in
the center of the
of this because of the various
government announcements of various
reading initiatives
and antes valley has ended up in the
front line
and ben over to you thanks fraser
um and yeah i think that's probably true
i think the reason we are at the
uh the forefront of a huge amount of the
government's net zero
uh ambitions is is because of that
traditional industry that we had
t-size as an area produces more carbon
than anywhere else in the country except
for the humber
and the humber itself has similar
geographical and socio-economic makeup
to the teas valley uh large chemical
large steel
um and so one of the biggest challenges
that we have which is why we've tried to
get
ahead of this is that the net zero
target
actually means that the large chemical
industry that we have
in the region which is the largest in
the country uh will not exist by 2050
unless we do something to tackle the
carbon carbon emissions so
this agenda is you know there is huge
opportunities for job creation
innovation new technologies
but actually a big part of it is
protecting the many thousands of jobs i
currently have in the chemical sector in
my region
as well as creating new jobs um and i
think
the net zero agenda is no more starkly
felt than in t
side because over the last five years
we've actually cut our carbon emissions
by nearly 50 percent and the reason we
did that is we closed the steel works
and put 3000 people out of work so it's
very easy to cook carbon emissions
if you want to put people out of work
and that is felt in post-industrial
areas of
places like teaside humberside parts of
the northwest
but the flip side of that is while there
is a huge
um danger that it will adversely affect
areas like t-side and others there is a
huge upside opportunity in it
because the infrastructure that we have
in the steel sector
in the chemical sector in the processing
sector but let's be honest
is in large parts of the north of
england that usually do sit within
areas of high deprivation
that infrastructure is the thing that
you can build net zero on
it's the reason for example that we have
net zero t
side which will be the world's first
industrial scale carbon capture
and storage facility that's a project
that's going to cost
somewhere between three and a half and
five billion pounds just to build
it's going to capture 10 million tons of
carbon out of the atmosphere the
equivalent of three million homes
the reason they've chosen here out of 22
sites in the whole of the world was
because of the existing chemical and
processing infrastructure
so there's a wonderful kind of um poetry
to this
transition from old industry through to
new industry
utilizing many of the same skills
because carbon capture things like
hydrogen things like offshore wind
utilize largely the same skills as
chemical processing and steel
which means that you're not putting
people on the rubbish heap in their
40s and 50s who are um you know finding
that their old industry is no longer
there but can they be reskilled into the
new one
um so i think there's a huge opportunity
for the north of england and this art
this discussion about leveling up is
that if we get it right
it could see the north reborn certainly
places like t-side reborn
as the uk center for low-carbon clean
growth
green technologies absolutely can be
done there is a
as lord kurzlich has said there is an
important role the government have to
play in this
because we can take a lead locally we
can absolutely um bring people together
to make these projects happen to an
extent but the biggest problem we face
i think are two things that the
government need to step up and make some
decisions on
one is a national regulatory framework
for these different technologies whether
that's carbon capture
coming up with a financial model that
the government accepts whether it's
hydrogen maybe some form of cfd like we
did with offshore wind
we need a regulatory framework for the
government to incentivize
the private sector to bring investment
into these technologies at the moment
the only people really playing in this
field are
you know the large for example net zero
t side is a conglomerate
of sorry a consortium of all of the big
oil and gas companies from bp
shell eni total equinox the people who
have the money to do this
but what we need is for the government
to send a signal that this is a market
that should be stimulated and give
confidence to the market to create it
and and just uh because there'll be lots
of questions where we can get into the
detail of this just one point that i
know has picked up about heating in the
home
um we could today significantly reduce
our carbon emissions by pumping 20
hydrogen into our gas network you can do
that today without changing
a single piece of technology or
anybody's boiler or any infrastructure
within the uk
um we can't do that at the moment until
the regulatory framework is put in place
to be able to do so if you want to get
you could in theory and i i am a strong
believer that you could easily move that
in the coming years to 100 but again the
regulatory framework needs to be there
to allow that to happen
because then you get the producers of
hydrogen coming in because you have the
economies of scale to produce that level
of hydrogen
and that then stimulates other
technologies in hydrogen because you get
you get volume which drives down price
because let's not forget at the minute
clean technologies like hydrogen well i
do believe they're the future they are
expensive
so we need economies of scale and volume
to drive down those prices and again
that's where the government
can help by setting up that regulatory
framework or actually reducing that
regulatory framework
to allow it um you know the market more
freedom to be able to to introduce these
technologies
and then the very very final point is
the scale of the task at hand
and again i'll stick with um heating of
the home
because irrespective of whether it's
hydrogen or something else whether it's
heat pumps or whether it's moving to
hydrogen and hydrogen boilers
there are you know just stick with me
here there are just under 30 million
homes in the uk
if you work backwards that means we've
got to replace a boiler
every 45 seconds every hour
of every day of every week of every year
from now until 2050.
that's a lot of boilers that's a huge
amount of work and that goes up
for every day that we continue to delay
the decision
of which direction are we going in and
what is the framework to allow that to
take place so
um i think we are potentially at the
start of something exciting
i think it could be hugely
transformational from the north to move
us from a post-industrial economy into
something new
uh but we need to get on with it because
other countries are passing us by and
this government needs to take some
decisions to make sure that we can grasp
those opportunities
ben thanks very much by my calculations
that's about
30 boilers by the time you've been
speaking there so that's a a lot of work
we need to do in this country
and finally let's hear from duncan bart
who's cop 26 director
of the national grid thanks fraser
um i was nodding away furiously to what
ben was saying there particularly around
the numbers um
as you know at national grid we've been
at the heart of the
very successful energy transition so far
in the uk that
quasi-quality was talking about earlier
and we can see
what needs to be done we think that
there is an absolutely golden
opportunity to put together
the the challenge and investment that
will be delivered through net zero
with the need to level up an awful lot
of the agenda around net zero will be
around
engineering will be around hard
industrial skills
and new skills and different
technologies strengths that
traditionally have sat in some of our
industrial heartlands and can be
re-enabled and rediscovered in those
heartlands as well
earlier this year we undertook a study
with discovery economics
looking at the scale of opportunity
around
the investment in challenge zero
and we found that over 400 000 jobs
will be created over the next 30 years
in order to deliver that transition just
in the energy sector
and we've recently been working with ben
uh and with policy exchange on a new
report looking at the economic
opportunity
for the north sea delivering very low
carbon energy with offshore wind
uh carbon capture and storage and
hydrogen and again
just for the communities there around
the north sea a huge opportunity of 20
billion pounds a year
as we unleash the investment that will
help us get to zero carbon
so there is an absolutely golden chance
we have now
to structure that net zero investment
in a way which not only delivers zero
carbon but which uses the best
of uk skills expertise and
infrastructure to make sure that we do
level it up
right across the nation and particularly
up and down the east coast
and thanks very much duncan now let's go
over to
questions at lord kurzlich i'd like to
and start with you
your um your 2070 gender is fascinating
but i do wonder how much of it has
changed we all know about the need to
level up
but i think that i wonder to what extent
the last few months have seen massive
massive leveling down we haven't begun
to calculate
we haven't really had time to work out
who've been the winners and the losers
of the last few months
but i think there wouldn't be any prizes
for guessing that inequality will have
widened massively in the country between
the regions within the regions
as andy holden was saying at the center
for city's presentation
and a few weeks ago but but to what
extent do you think you actually might
need to almost come up with a new report
to find out and that where
whereabouts of the leveling up agenda is
now given that it might take us years
to level up to get back to where we were
at the start of this year
yes it's a good uh challenge and that's
why we did in fact do
a fourth report um uh which we published
in september that looked very precisely
at how kobe did affected things
and kovit has been has definitely not
been a leveler has definitely
hit those most vulnerable hardest uh and
that's true
regionally as well as terms of
individuals so there's going to need to
be some here and now
action uh to address those who are
most affected by covet but at the core
of
our argument is that we will not in a
sense recover
fully economically from the impact of
covert
unless we do leveling up at the same
time
we can in a sense deliver the growth we
need sustainably
if we go back to the old model of all
the growth happening
in london and the southeast there has to
be a more balanced approach to this
and it's going to have an impact
environmentally if we go back to that
old way as well in terms of uh
impact on a whole set of issues on
resources
the traffic congestion house prices and
so on so you have to combine leveling up
with economic growth and we won't in a
sense be able
to pay back the costs of covid unless we
grow the worst thing of all we could do
is go back into
an austerity driven process just at this
point in time
so from my point of view as i touched on
earlier
kovitch has uh if you like made the
challenge
harder in very specific ways which we
set out in our report
but it's also made the leveling up
agenda even more
imperative i think and what we did do in
that report was highlight where
we thought you could start the process
of change over the next uh
five years so i don't think it's changed
the agenda i don't think
in any sense the tasks the ten tasks
that we set out
have altered what i do think is that the
urgency of taking action
has definitely gone up right but if i
can just um
come back a little bit you mentioned
that i mean so far uh
the or or rather until until when kobet
came along
the argument was that look it's a false
dichotomy between
2050 agenda and leveling up you can do
both
you can get green jobs green growth and
now
you know we all know that uh that's um
if you're
subsidizing energy if you're making
people's electricity bills
more expensive by regulation or by tanks
or by anything else
this doesn't do a great deal to help
inequality it makes it worse
but maybe that's a price worth paying to
get towards a a
20 50 target in other words until
january didn't seem as if there was much
of a conflict
i'm wondering that women eventually we
start to recover now we're by the way
just about to face another national
lockdown
another sharp economic contraction
another massive
increase of inequality whether the job
of trying to repair the damage
might have to come before um the
environmental agenda whether we might
have to think okay
we can return to the sort of the 2050
agenda as we envisaged it
once we managed to get i don't know gdp
up to
um only four percent below what it was i
mean might we now be
perceiving the conflict between
environmentalism and between economic
growth a bit more acutely
as we try to repair the immediate damage
of lockdown
i can see the temptation of that
argument but i don't see it that way i
think
actually some of the actions we can take
can deliver on
all of the agendas to give one example
um
if we're going to be off of gas and
moving to more expensive electricity
then as people have touched on we should
be investing improving
the energy efficiency of our homes
there's a huge
opportunity there that would if both at
the same time as
we move to more sustainable models of
energy
also avoid the need for costs to go up
precipitately so i actually genuinely
believe
we are it's a false choice that you're
putting uh here
fraser i think we can both do things
that stimulate the economy investment in
infrastructure
transport in the way that andrew spoke
about that will both
help economic growth and it will
uh i think take forward the agenda of
leveling up and indeed it will take for
the agenda of
um zero carbon as well and i really
would almost put the question the other
way around if we simply go back to what
we were doing before apricot
uh we'll reinforce some of the great uh
inequalities
we already have so of course we're going
to need short-term stuff to preserve
jobs like the furlough scheme
but the investment in economic growth
needs to be
both sustainable and uh rebalance at the
same time i do think it's possible to
achieve that but what we don't have at
the moment and i'll just finish with
this bike razor
we don't have a plan if you ask me how
we're going to achieve leveling up
in this country what's the government's
plan for this i don't know what it is
and i think they desperately need to
develop a plan for it
ben houchin is the reason we don't have
a plan because we're still
in free fall right now with no real idea
where we're going to
end up when it comes to rebuilding the
economy and we
therefore we're not quite sure how the
environmental agenda can go with it
i think the issue that we've got is for
for years now there's been a meandering
of what what are we actually trying to
achieve
so my biggest frustration with with
government um
since i was elected in 2017 is that
where we're getting to for example on
hydrogen
we were talking to government about
three years ago and
they then decided that they were going
to go into their own little bubble and
set up a hydrogen team
and they were then going to spend 18
months going out across the country and
finding out what the
the live the land was and then they
might look at some technologies and then
they might come up with a policy
and some sort of strategy and now we're
with three years on
and i understand later this year there
will be a hydrogen strategy produced i'm
fairly confident that strategy
is going to say what we told them three
years ago so a big problem that we've
had and actually i think there's a you
know it often happens in times of crisis
i think what it actually will do is
focus the mind of government
to start to get onto and to deliver some
of these things
because there is the imperative from the
civil service that they have taken
years to come up with what the regions
think of fairly simple solutions because
we've been working on them
for decades now i mean hydrogen is not a
new technology to t side we've been
using it for half a century
um and then now there's a political
imperative to show not just leveling up
but short-term leveling up as part of
the corolla virus agenda so
um in all honesty it's typical
government policy making that civil
servants
don't want to make recommendations and
put a proposal together because there's
this whole argument of not picking
winners and losers whereas actually what
they should have done
is and i would say this is a regional
mayor they should have devolved some of
that responsibility to the regions that
are going to be generating this
technology and already produce it
because we would have got there a lot
sooner um so actually i think covert is
probably starting to focus the minds
more for them to get on and start making
decisions
which i think we'll see in the next
couple of months around ccos and things
like hydrogen and indeed offshore wind
i mean we've lost more than 12 000 jobs
in t-side since the start of kovid
if we are able to work with government
on what we're trying to do and land some
of the offshore wind manufacturing in t
side
we think just in direct jobs that will
replace
75 of those lost we think offshoring
could easily generate 9 000 direct jobs
in our region um those are decisions
that you know government can get on and
make
by twisting the arms of some of the
manufacturers so there's this idea of
this short-term need to address
kovid that's not going to happen
overnight but there is a short-term need
but i just don't want us to go back to
this knee-jerk reaction of
let's be honest leveling up in the north
of england's going to take years
decades of under investment by
governments of all colors
in hard infrastructure never mind the
soft stuff around skills and aspiration
we still need to maintain our eye on a 5
10 15
20 year horizon because that's how long
it's going to take if we
really want to level up the uk as a
whole rather than just our
our city centers in the traditional
south of england
okay question now from lynne mcfarlane
it's for you
andrew carter so and she asks if ben
hootson here
is the aristocrat of the new green
regime if basically the cheese valley
is in the is in line for a lot of the
good things that are going to come a lot
of the investments
a lot of the new technologies will be
centered there
but are there not within and within
these areas
lots of inequality are there not lots of
places that will be
that you can fairly easily describe as
net
losers out of a new energy regime we're
heading towards
yeah so it's a good um question uh
describing ben as an aristocrat i'll
leave him to come back on
that might be a new label i don't i
don't know but that was one of the
reasons why
you know i think the agenda that ben has
set out um
you know is at the sort of technology
and innovation end and that's incredibly
important one of the reasons i didn't
talk so much about that
and actually talked about fairly mundane
everyday things
like um making our homes more energy
efficient
helping people to access public
transport rather than necessarily
getting their car building more homes
which we know new homes are much more
energy
efficient uh increasing density in urban
areas because that drives
productivity which drives better jobs
better wages
those are the kind of skilled effects
and benefits that will not only benefit
the you know the very
you know a smaller number of people that
are actually directly employed or
indirectly employed in
the hydrogen technology frontier but
actually benefit all of these sorts of
places and i think that's part of the
agenda
it's not only to focus on the sort of
high technological end
but actually ask the question what can
we be doing
across the piece to make our places more
productive
uh have good employment and as a result
of that all through that
uh reduce energy and i think that would
be you know you would see
more winners that way rather than uh
focus on
uh on the losers okay
okay a question for duncan burts it's
from peter haynes and to what extent
do you think that as the government
tries to come up with this agenda is
going to end up having to change it
again because simply so much
is in flux right now on regional
inequality and in much
of the way that the economic future is
being reshaped
i guess um one of the main things here
is
look what's happening to the energy
sector in general right now we're
getting trends that we never would have
thought
even six months ago even before covert
came along we had
a conflict between the saudis and the
russians which conspired to
put um a price of all below zero dollars
a barrel which
threatened american shale there is just
so much
up in the air right now so surely any if
the government attempts to come up with
a longer term plan it's going to be one
which is going to have to need to be
updated
just as as surely as lord kurzlich's
commission has come up with a new report
early months after they published their
first one
things are very volatile and uncertain
due to covid for
nearly every sector around the world at
the moment that's that's true and
no one would argue with that i think and
uh we still don't know
how and when we will precisely come out
of that economically and from a business
cycle of perspective as well but there
are some really
hard truths in there which stand out the
first one is that
the whole world is now moving towards
net zero
and so the uk that means we need to get
on board quickly
so that we can make the industrial and
economic advantages of being one of the
first movers
into our supply chains and into our
industry infrastructure to make those
changes ahead and therefore
keep those sites open keep them working
successfully under a new regime
we have china and europe now committing
to net zero as
the minister said earlier and
if if dependent on what happens in the
u.s election we see the u.s moving that
way as well we would have more than
two-thirds
of global economic activity and global
carbon emissions targeted at net zero
between 2050 and 2060.
now if i'm someone like ben arguing
strongly for development in the north i
would absolutely agree with his urgency
if we move quickly and see that
investment
enabled by government then we can grow
and we can move
our industry faster so that we become
zero carbon and we become the winners in
that transition
the risk and challenge of waiting or
delaying is that
we will hold back and our sites will
close and other sites in japan or in
india
or in china will stay open instead and
supply those feedstocks of hydrogen
steel or other produce so there's there
are real risks here as well as
opportunities
and and the opportunities really are
quite unique to the uk we're in a very
strong position
okay a question for ben houchin from
allison rodwell
ben you say you gave the example of
saving carbon by closing industries such
as steel
which will then result in job losses
surely
this will end up with us having to
import steel with a higher carbon
footprint
while deepening our own regional
inequality at the same time
she goes on to say the same could be
said of coal production if we still need
a certain amount of coal
and then shouldn't we produce low carbon
coal here
instead of importing well i think it's
an interesting point on steel and
it's it's it's one unfortunately it's an
argument we lost
five years ago with the closure of the
red castile works but it is one that is
very live in port albert at the minute
um with the the potential bailout
whether that's going to happen or not we
we just don't know but
in all honesty if you want my opinion on
port tolbert if they did get a bailout
of the numbers that are being talked
about they'll be back to government in
four or five years time
asking for the same thing and there's a
real risk actually that
tata could just hand over the keys to
the government having
put hundreds and hundreds of millions of
pounds into a very carbon intensive
industry
which is just increasingly uncompetitive
in traditional bas furnace steel making
there there isn't there are actually
options for the uk government that i've
tried to discuss with them
we have seen large international steel
makers especially from north america
who are looking to bring electric arc
furnace steel making to the uk
and every time i speak to one in
particular who's very interested in
potentially bringing it to t
side they're infuriated by the idea that
the government would bail out
port talbot again to the tune of what it
would cost to build
a brand new state-of-the-art steel plant
that is low carb and electric arc
furnace
and would displace a huge amount of
exports of scrap steel because
we we tend to export roughly 12 million
tons of
scrap steel every single year we tend to
import
a similar amount that has gone to turkey
and then has gone through electric arc
furnaces and then we re-imported a
slight at a higher cost
we obviously outsource the manufacturing
jobs that can come from that
so i think again it's about boxing
clever isn't it so there is a there is a
there is genuinely a place
for steel making in the uk and that
isn't all traditional bass furnace
technology
not just for net zero purposes but
economically we can't compete with
emerging
markets like those in the far east where
that is still done but what we can do is
we can do it at the high end
and we absolutely can be internationally
competitive and that's what you need to
ask government to
you know my overall plan would be build
an electric arc furnace steel plant in t
side it's low carbon it's recycling
steel you stick it in the middle of a
free zone
which means that manufacturing becomes
more competitive which means you're
actually competitive with the likes of
thailand
and china in the far east when you're
re-exporting your steel internationally
when you're displacing domestic markets
as well
so actually i think again it's about
this idea that government needs to be a
bit more joined up in its regulatory
framework
where in the in the context of net
cereal coal's a really interesting one
because for example there's been a
big dispute recently over the uh open
cast mining cumbria
that would potentially benefit in part t
side because
interestingly enough the the cumbria of
mine is talking about exporting huge
amounts of that coal
through t sport the river tease now the
argument for that open cast mine was
that it would displace
imports but the cumbria mine are talking
about exporting
many millions of tons of it so i often
take those things with a pinch of salt
however that's why we need a sensible
transition
and it's why i've never understood the
argument of you know we need to be net
zero by 2025 or 2030. it is impossible
you cannot do it without costing
thousands of jobs
um energy security disappearing energy
costs going through the roof
which is why i'm such a supporter of
carbon capture because carbon capture
isn't the solution
but what it is is a transition to low
carbon technologies
while that technology is still
developing so it helps maintain low
energy costs
it helps reduce carbon in the atmosphere
it helps create jobs
on that transition to 2050 because that
can be in you know net zero t side could
be built by 2026
you're talking about five and a half
thousand construction jobs
is continuing to produce natural gas
power plants that plug into carbon
capture the
the answer clearly not but actually that
is a transition that could easily
last you 50 or 60 years while over the
next 10
20 years you're looking at things like
hydrogen offshore wind
nuclear and the other energy mix because
i actually think fundamental to the
problems we're facing especially in our
energy market
is the lack of a government policy and
the delay and delay and delay of the
energy white paper causes more
uncertainty
which is actually leading to higher
costs so
government needs to kind of just get on
and make some decisions so
the private sector and investors can can
get on and invest in the infrastructure
that's needed lord kirsten what do you
think of ben
hutchins points there i mean is it
simply time to tell
port alberts and other similar
communities that their technologies
blast furnace or
whatever basically belong in the past
and that there isn't
any bailout which is going to stop them
coming to the same crisis point three or
four years down the line
so now simply is the time to bite the
good realign their economies
uh another word i mean we can't keep we
can't go on telling everybody they're
going to be a winner from this
agenda and as new technologies come on
someplace
simply isn't it the time to retire some
old
um old technology isn't that in a way
longer term
kinder than keeping something going if
we knew there's no long-term future in
it
unquestionably some technology some
industries are going to
not be part of the future i think we can
see that now and i'm in
sheffield and indeed south yorkshire saw
massive change
with the closing of the coal fields for
example
so we're definitely going through a
transition and some of the high carbon
industries will
not survive really the key question is
do you let that process happen
kind of unplanned and in a chaotic way
with huge
personal and human damage or do you plan
the transition and sustain the
transition from our
traditional industries to new industries
and i just think
it can be done people know that this is
the kind of world we're going to have to
move into
but without a kind of clear sense of
government's uh
policy on this and local initiative
locally empowered leaders
then they're going to resist it because
they can't see what the future is
so absolutely do are we going to need to
change
definitely how do we do that change is
the key question and how we
how do we carry uh communities with us
on this
uh on this journey i think is the key
point and we've got plenty of examples
of not doing it very well
let's try and see if we can through the
kind of local leadership that ben brings
do it better this time
and duncan burts and is given that we
will as an economy we're always going to
need to
steal it's not going to go away so
wouldn't it make sense
simply just to find ways of making it a
low-carbon version of steel
here rather than using the old trick of
importing abroad
exporting our carbon emissions and
congratulating ourselves for
helping the environment in the way that
which we're not actually doing we're
just outsourcing the problem
i think you could you could say that for
still you can say that for a whole range
of industrial products
processes and manufacturing as well that
the uk will have
some of the lowest carbon electricity in
the world um so why wouldn't you want to
make stuff in the uk
using low carbon power rather than using
a higher intensity power elsewhere if we
can get the local engagement if we can
get the infrastructure and the costs
right and we can move quickly
in a way that exactly as ben's talking
about and andrew's talking about in the
development of cities
so there really is we you know i
we wholeheartedly support the
government's industrial strategy of
industrial clusters the development
around humber and t side is a great
example of how we can
start to build very significant indus
new industrial hubs with ccs with
hydrogen
and with all of the heavy and lighter
industrial processes that could benefit
from
from low carbon electricity the duck new
director of cop26
national grid i imagine that you
actually would have thought you'd be out
of a job by now in
the original timetable um what are you
thinking for next year do you think it
might be a cop
26 in 2022 that's right
no i think we i mean we are delighted by
what's happened over the last few months
in terms of the international
commitments we've seen from china
from japan from south korea we're
obviously watching events
in the united states very closely to see
what happens there and
but so far we have the powerhouses of
asia joining
uh the european union in some very very
significant
long-term commitments to zero
not just across energy but across
agriculture and the whole economy
and that that means huge things for all
of us
in terms of the uk being able to lead
and so the uk government as it is
pushing in the right direction to try
and take a lead both in industrial
processes
in manufacturing and in the development
of clusters of low carbon technology
which means that we can not only
be one of the leading nations in terms
of low carbon but we can also develop
technologies
and processes here that we can export
around the world to the benefit of the
uk
and my final question to you andrew
carter and when we are looking at
regional inequalities do you think it's
fair to say that there will be
winners and losers out of this i mean
right now it's funny in discussions like
this we talk as if
there are no trade-offs to be made
nobody's going to be poorer as a result
of this
that everybody will be a winner i mean
right now
we don't have to go very far to see
there's some real problems and some real
hardship being faced by our countries
and some place some cities
are going to face it simply a lot more
than than others
and so office cities and do you think
it's fair to say that there are winners
and leaders
and we ought to be talking a bit more
frankly about the losers
and what more can be done for them
because not everybody is as
geographically best blessed as cheese
valley well
i mean part of the problem frasier is
that you know
too many places outside of the greater
south east would be currently classed as
losers
and in a sense that is the challenge
that is presented
to us and there's absolutely no reason
at all i mean we are unique as bob was
saying
you know think about our big cities like
manchester and leeds and
liverpool right all of those
underperform the national average on a
whole range of
economic and social indicators that
isn't the case when you go to other oecd
countries
so there is no reason why we should have
the pattern
that we observe they are the current
losers and the question is
how do we get those places and others
middlesbrough and such
to be better performers in absolute
terms then we can start worrying about
whether
the difference between one place and
another uh is reducing uh or growing
part of the problem is is that the
greater southeast is where
much of our economic activity originates
and there's an
awful lot we can do to create more
winners
in more places before i think we really
need to worry about
whether we're trading off one place
compared to the next i think we've got
an awful lot of space
to work on before we even need to worry
about that
okay and andrew carter thanks very much
and thank you to all our panelists lord
kurzlich
and duncan bart